so the first speaker is
teresa
we'll talk about
computational approaches to study
interactions between metadata processes
and cellular
processes
okay thank you robert and um i'll try to
starting start by thanking the
organizers
and others for a kind invitation to
participate in this workshop it's been
really honored it was wonderful to
listen to all this stuff
so i hope you know my talk will lift to
the expectations here
and be as great and all the
other presentations so for the last
couple of years my group in um
working on uh understanding of uh
mutagenic processes muslin cancer but
also by extension metagenic processes
also in in other
in
s with application to other diseases
so um
[Music]
okay
so um
as you know um uh antenna dna in
every
individual cell is subject to constant
constant damage this damage can be
imposed by just
exposure to
naturally
you know
existing
environmental factors this damage may be
also related to stochasticity and error
prone processes in the within the cells
uh the the areas related to replications
and uh
in fact uh it's been estimated that and
on average a cell can accumulate not
accumulated but can i can uh be subject
of about 10 to 5 lesions per cell per
day
so fortunately most of those lesions are
very efficiently repaired by dna repair
processes
that
a cell developed and only a small number
of
of
those lesions
leak out remain unrepaired and they will
lead to two mutations
as i mentioned this this process is very
efficient and
and those are the the number of those uh
some authentication remains to be very
small but uh
unless you know the the amount of dna
damage is really high or perhaps in some
cases when the dna repair is not as
efficient as it's expected to be this
accumulation may be much more
significant and eventually leading to
cancer
so
recently
the question the the studies related to
understanding of those neutrogenic
processes in cancer but also in other
other contexts have received a wonderful
boost thanks to
to to study of alexander at all
so it has been already appreciated for a
long time that certain
motogenic processes tend to leave
characteristic mutational patterns into
human genomes for example uv light is
known to
to preferentially mutate c to t
however this those um probability of
this um
mutation of c to t is context dependent
and is uh particularly uh
present when we have uh
the c is preceded by t so those are
basically t2c to t2 mutation
uv light is not the only process that
has this um type of characteristic
mutation pattern and one of the uh
important contribution of the study of
alexander also proposed that we should
really look and have a general framework
a common way of representing those
mutational processes though those
characteristic pattern that we are going
to refer now as mutational signatures so
here i will uh
i will follow the the definition of
mutational signatures proposed in the
study
and basically the idea is that we are
going to consider mutational categories
so for this for this step status
mutation categories would be a triple a
triple of nucleotides where the central
nucleotide is the one that's mutated and
two additional nucleotides are provided
for the context
so this leads to 96 mutation categories
uh up there you have um the
summary of the mutation of the central
residual
c two a c two g c two three and one down
here that you cannot quite see are those
are all this possible combination of the
flanking residue
so uh
once we
with this formalism we can look at some
other noun uh
noun uh mutations that
are not to have character segmentation
patterns so for example
uh the
enzyme apobic enzyme that are being um
that's known to
to uh mutate single sentence dna uh has
again characteristic mutation pattern is
again c2c but the context is quite
different
the the um
some of the chemicals in cigarette
smoking have yet another pattern and
various drugs we might have the in the
individual uh mutation patterns
so of course uh
currently
the the number of various agents that
may
uh
contribute such mutations signatures are
no but looking from the other end
starting from the definition this
general definition of mutation signature
we can ask the question
uh
what are the mutational signatures
that are needed to explain
um
mutations inside cancer genomes
that are available to us
so to to answer this question uh again
this is uh alexandra proposed to just
simply use the non-negative
factorization starting with the data
that
takes all the
samples of of
a
cancer
available cancer can cancer
samples and then
starting with this count matrix where
each uh each column corresponds to one
of this
each of those 96 mutational categories
and then counting for for every
individuals we count how many mutations
in each categories we have so we have
this count matrix and the question is
you know identify those mutation
signatures
defined by those uh
profiles uh probability profiles as
shown on the previous slide so that uh
you know all those mutation counts can
be uh explained as linear combination of
those signatures
so uh
we are as i say we are going to refer to
those
those
signatures as cosmic signatures they are
being um
deposited in cosmic database
um
then and one more thing is uh since uh
basically what we are having here is
um we represent all the mutation in the
genome as linear combination of those of
those signatures so the coefficient of
this linear recommendation for a given
signature will be referred to exposure
and uh is a good uh
terminology because for example uh
looking at the
um
smoking signatures the signatures
associated with smoke
we can see that really exposure and and
the amount of of the mutations that's
attributed to the signature is related
to the
uh the
yearbook cigarettes so related to how
much given individual smoke so it's as i
say
it makes sense to think about
this coefficient as the strength of the
of the mutational process
okay
okay
so i'll give the um
following again the same studies
applying uh in first time uh applying
this non-negative matrix factorization
in 2013 to uh to the um cancer genomes
that were available at this point uh
the author identified 30 different
cosmic signature subsequently later
study 2020
with a much bigger cohort a key map with
a larger much larger set of signatures
here are some examples of the signatures
as i identify here by numbers
and of course would like to now
understand what's the relation between
those computational the right signatures
and metadata processes in in cancer and
some of those signatures were
immediately could be immediately
recognized and well understood and for
some of them
we can only propose some vague
relationship so for example there are
three signatures known to be uh we call
it clock-like signatures that seem to be
increased with the patient's age
out of those signature one is well
understood as is related to metal
surfacing and the uh
damination so this process that happens
naturally during replication so the more
replication cycle the bigger
recombination accumulation of the
signature you may have
but the remaining two are are more vague
and then again going through at least
some of the signatures are maybe
understood so for example signatures for
related to smoking but still uh doesn't
tell us exactly what the direction it
what is the mechanistic relation
to smoking
and then many of those are really dna
signatures 11 dna cleaving agents but
what signature 11 and not some other
pattern is still very interesting to
know
so how we are going to now go around and
try to understand deeper those know the
relations of those mutational patches
that we discover with the specific
methodogenic processes uh that may occur
in in in cancer
um
first of all why why do we care
obviously you know answering questions
is very big basic questions always
interesting would like to understand the
uh
cancer genesis
in general
but it's also important from the
perspective
more direct application uh to understand
uh say for prevention if we can
identify certain
mutation signature and link it to some
experimental uh exposures then
you know we understand so much and we
know that which you know the individual
should avoid this
exposure since immutability but also uh
is also important for therapy
so some of those amatogenic processes
are related uh
with a deficiency of dna repair
machinery
that for example in breast cancer
homogeneous recombination deficiency is
very uh you know is very
abundant so if we understand
the uh
dna deficient dna repair deficiency
associated with given signatures
then this may propose you know what is
the complementary pathways that the
cancer cell use to overcome and by using
a synthetic lethality uh you know
hitting this complementary pathway may
selectively kill the cancer cell so this
is in fact the the idea behind behind
prp inhibitors uh being applied to
to
breast cancer with homogeneous
recombination deficiency but also later
on you know once uh been appreciated
that homologous recombination deficiency
is associated with specific signature uh
this therapy could be also brought to
say also ovarian cancer that had that
signatures and therefore suggesting
that's homologous accommodation and so
on there are other signatures that are
associated again uh work well with
immuno
immunotherapy and so on so it's really
understanding what are the signature and
how they are associated with biological
processes is relevant for therapy
okay
so um
how we can uh start and and uh
how we can start you know discovering
those those relationship the the deeper
the molecular and other underpinning of
mutation signatures so um there's many
things that some efficient signature are
associated with many processes they may
be as associated with
general mutations such as
braca
they as i mentioned they are associated
with the environment
and also we can study uh study the
um
uh
the
underpinning and perhaps a relationship
of the mutation signature but study uh
the relationship with the changes in the
in the molecular network and passwords
so um in in this talk i'm going to
explore the
uh
relationship between mutation signatures
to gene expression cell type composition
mutated gene network and also
interaction between different dna uh
damage and repair i don't expect to be
able to provide uh
you know to explain all of those with
this great details they are mostly
focused on gene expression and mutated
network and i'm going to just uh touch
the remaining tool
so that
to emphasize what sort of challenges
might be hidden behind
okay so gene expression
so uh
we would um there's a good reason to
one way to understand to understand uh
you know what's happening what what are
the uh what the given process or
different signatures related to would be
to study uh the changes in gene
expression that correlates with the
strength of that signature so to do that
we develop a very simple approach
um which simply uh based on on basic
basic correlation this was not the first
uh
the first ideas that we had but it was
the first one that actually worked
so um assume that we have for many
cancer patients we have data both for
mutational data and gene expression data
so this is uh this method can be
applied only to those cancers and also
would be uh preferentially also for
would like to
utilize here those uh status that has
whole genome sequencing so that we have
a a good uh
count of those mutational processes but
in general in this case we have for
every patients we have gene expression
for every for every gene so we have this
gene expression matrix by patient and
also for also patients we have the
matrix um
that gives us a strength of the
signature so there's a for every cancer
type just a limited number of signatures
that are actually present and for each
of the signature we can compute its
exposure or sometimes i will also call
it signature strength so we have a
patient by signatures
and patient by genes so then we can for
for every
now for every pair of gene and signature
we can compute whether or not there is
correlation between a given signature
and given patient
and
which will give us this
genes by signature matrix for which we
are going only to keep
those genes which have a significant
correlation with at least one signature
so after this filtering we simply
cluster those um
those
genes by
uh the relation with signatures patterns
and once we have those clusters uh we
will try to uh interpret them by kind of
uh
basic uh utilizing uh
go enrichment analysis
and so that too to see what are the
basic processes that those clusters
might be related with
so this is a
indeed very simple approach and as you
will see you will have some benefits and
also
very quickly you will see that it has
some limitations
so this is the application
of this clustering technique to the
breast cancer down here our signature up
here i wrote what's known about them so
the first of the signature is one of
this clock-like signature this is
another clock-like signature those those
those things that are here are related
to upper back enzyme and this is
homologous recombination deficiency and
signature eight that uh it's not really
understood
so uh immediately what what we can see
and um
on on the right here are the uh
enrichment of the processes that
that are for those in clusters of genes
with with provided patterns
so as you can see the the the power uh
there are some things that we there's a
lot interesting information that we gain
but there are also some linked for
example um signature five which is not
well understood um we can really
appreciate that immense clock signature
is quite different uh from signature one
which is the one which is better
understood which is known to be
correlated with cell cycle
uh because replication related so indeed
pops up on our analysis and correlated
with cell cycle signature five is not
so they certainly we have two signatures
that stick to different clocks we still
ah and are looking uh for a hint we can
see that there is and
there's a correlation with a bunch of
strings here and this related nuclear
nucleotide excision repair pathways so
we have it doesn't give a quite
mechanism but at least give us some
sense that
this is likely to be related to some
perhaps environmental uh uh processes
that are uh uh
you know
uh repaired by this repair pathway
um however um still uh we didn't gain
any knowledge about signature eight
we know that signature apobic signature
homologous recombination signatures
seems to be correlated with each other
uh we were hoping that by this analysis
we will
learn
which of those come first whether this
is homologous recombination that will uh
stimulate upper back pathway
but clearly uh there are limitations for
this one
so um before i will go to our next kind
of try how we are going to avoid and how
we are going to
uh to um
resolve some of this limitation i wanted
to just uh show one more application of
this approach since uh covet 19
um longhouse is of on everybody minds so
we thought you know there's so much uh
uh so one of the important metagenic
processes is smoking right and uh
smoking is not you know
an individual that smokes uh you know
damages his or her lung cancer with no
cancer
and then we so we have the idea that we
can use the cancer data of lung cancer
data which has uh uh quite a few account
control sample and see how smoking
affects based on the signature effect
of the gene expression in those control
samples
so again so this time we are using here
control samples so we use gene
mutation signatures that read out of
mutation and signatures that we get from
the cancer but we look at the gene
expression from in from control samples
so we can learn from it very quickly is
that signature 4 which is smoking
signature those those are smoking
greatest signatures signature one this
is the the one clock-like cell cycle
signature and 213 those are upper back
signatures and perhaps uh as
i should have mentioned that those two
signatures are often
seen as related to immune response and
indeed this is what we see we see that
um smoking signature is related with
cytokine magnesium signaling pathways um
uh um there's also another immunorelated
cluster that
composed all this more more of those
signatures
yep
the original slightly short correlation
between individual genes and signatures
here i guess he chose a gene group
oh so
you know once we have those genes in
signature here we clustered that
so now we are those clusters of the
genes that have the same pattern
right
so so yeah
uh so so those are those questions that
allows us to look at the replacement
analysis so those are the so there's
also interesting cluster here that is
negatively correlated with this serium
organization and from the previous talk
you
remember that
an important
component of caveat and in comparative
component of many other lung diseases is
the fact that there is a reprogramming
of the cell types
so based on this uh gun enrichment
analysis we already can see that uh that
there's um you know uh there may be
relationship decrease in selected cells
maybe increasing on some other cells and
what i show here are markers known
markers of different cell type in lag
this is book data but thanks to to
a significant effort in the single cell
analysis for rank we know for all this
individual third certified we know the
gene expression profile so we can use
them methods that decompose bulk data
into individual samples so we did this
and then we can really see that smoking
increased the amount of goblet itself
this this property of smoking have been
appreciated before using single cell
analysis but it was also appreciated
that smoking is um reducing the number
of ciliated cells and what we can see
that really the reduction of the
cellular concert is related not uniquely
to smoking but to other signatures that
is often called curing to smoking and a
little bit also to the signature too
which is immune related so we get some
inside also from this that may not be
accessible with other method
nevertheless
uh there's all only as much as we can
get from clustering as you could see
um so uh especially remember going back
to the the slide related to breast
cancer
the resolution of the whole
how analysis was was limited so in the
next uh
um
in this is still unpublished so in
currently worker are trying to
bypass this limitation so
what's the the problem that we
that we face is we have a lot of
correlation everything is basically
correlated with cancer growth
so what uh by about our proposed here
say well of course you know what you
deal with too much of correlation you
know you try to control you try to have
partial correlation controlling for all
the compounding effects
so
what you propose here well let's build a
network that will contain two types of
nodes genes and signatures
and then uh we know that for every genes
we have gene expressions for foreign
genes we have the expression profile
across the samples for every signature
we have signature exposure across the
sample
and
we would like to understand the the um
correlation between those those those
factors when we control for all the
other confronting factors
so the idea here is now to compute a
residual correlation between between um
and the two nodes by accounting for
other confounding factors
now uh this is being done simple um
by
um
just going ahead you you can say that at
the end we are going to have partially
directed network when some of the edges
will be will have positive correlation
some of them will have negative
correlation for some of them will have
some directions for some of them we will
not
so the idea is to take every individual
genes and and uh using us as
specifications of sparse
sparse partial correlation technique
which will consist on the idea that for
every genes we try to find small number
of genes so that as a linear combination
of the expression of these genes explain
an expression of that
i say expression i mean i really i
should say activity because we have a
mixed uh network of of um
of uh signatures and uh and uh dates
there will be uh so this uh because of
the specification uh
many there will be many edges that will
be directed into one direction because
we say okay this this gene is important
to explain the at the expression pattern
uh for this one but maybe uh it was not
pick up in the opposite direction when
you have the biodirectional edges uh we
i just additionally additionally i have
the
benefit that since we look at the
partial correlation so we have here the
residual correlation and we have two
variables that we know that are related
but if there are no confounding factors
then uh the the often one of the
statistical techniques to orient the
address is to assume
that the um the direction the correct
direction is from the variable that is
uh
that the direction
the target the target
variable is the one that is closer to
normality so the one that is kind of
distributed is this
so so that's additional additional step
to help us to
to come with this um
direction
it doesn't
does
better so this is random this is we use
here uh
uh
data database which has transfer factor
uh
uh
target gene uh relationship so it's a
limited and it's not uh relative because
our you know our network has and all
different type of disease but in general
those are this is how it well it does in
breast cancer and and
long
not perfect better than you know better
than by chance and better than a
simple
simple regression tree
okay
so but but with this uh so that in
summary we have the editors we have to
take them a little bit with grind
of salt they are not that they are not
that there are some significant
positive and negative here
but now we can understand the this is
the braca network and understand it much
better as we can clearly see now for
example that this is homologous
recombination deficiencies that cause a
public signature not the other way
around two minutes
oh my
but we could also i also appreciate that
for the signatures that we didn't know
uh how it uh what it does it's now
clearly related to uh to uh nerve
pathways
now um
we can ask additional similar questions
now previously we asked you know how the
gene expression can explain those
mutations and signatures we now ask how
mutated genes or networks might be
really associated with with mutational
processes for example we know that
bracawan mutation cause homologous
recommendation deficiency other
mutations uh are known because
efcc2 signature five so our next
question is they can we find mutated
pathways that will be associated with
the
uh with the signatures for for that we
utilize the methods that we previously
developed for drugs and sensitivity when
we ask similar questions they can refine
mutation pathways that are associated
with continuous phenotype defined by
drug sensitivity here we replace the
draxon's
sensitivity with the
um
strength of the given signature and ask
you know what are the uh what are the uh
mutated pathways that are associated
with us
with a
strength of the signature treated as
continuous phenotypes for example
signature five here three here which is
known to be homologous recombination
deficiency
uh clearly is associated with bracawan
braca 2 and also tp53
so um
and also the the other you know the
other signature some of the other
signature we have been able to i to to
find the the
mutations that are um
in some ways the best sub network that i
need the best way explain this this
mutational processes
and uh i know that i'm running out of
time but i would like to just to to
mention uh just this um
model as an open question
we've made some progress in in in this
is that
uh you know as as uh this initial slide
shows that um
what's cap our our mutation signature
which is the the end process of those of
of of this pathway is similarly that is
really related to things the two things
is dna damage which is super impulse
with dna repair so dna repair deficiency
interacts with dna damage and you can
have as many different signature as many
combination of those and we indeed have
it so for example here are two mismatch
repair signatures very different
are those different aspects of this
mismatch repair or is it the case that
that this one with much repair signature
is somehow
occurs in the cancers that have some
specific additional damage and this is
in uh with the different ones so this is
the the the last explanation is the
correct one
so we have to uh to do to capture that
we cannot anymore use non-negative
matrix factorization and assume that
there is a linear combination but we
have to use the models that will be able
to capture this type of interaction so
so this is one thing that we developed
but as there's a lot of um
additional um additional questions that
may be asked another question is again
uh
as uh
we know and
the
uh uh maybe not
okay it was known for the biologists at
least that that really uh mutation
mutations do not hit
every genes every region of the genes
with the same probability
but the
prepared processes are developed are
emerged so that the uh
for example mismatch repair is actively
recruited to active genes so that they
repair you know the genes and the the
the uh first there are some
mechanisms that are associated with
transcriptions specifically
so there's lots of uh so this is not all
um you know
all probability distribution fits all
regions so it's also important to to to
understand that that there will be a
dependency of the of the mutational
processes on the specific region so
that's another
thing that that um
that needs to be included in those
methods so just to summarize
um the the concept of mutational
processes uh the mutation signature
provides a very convenient and very
actually powerful way and way to
thinking about those mutations or
linking it to
to uh to the biological processes uh and
and
uh helping to understand uh standards
this is some of the tools that we
developed and also the the
uh
another open question is
how uh what are the different ways we
can infer those mutational signatures
that will be uh help us to to capture
the fact that the processes that are
being involved are not necessarily
additive and with that i would like to
thank my group and funding and
collaborators
yep
and this comes up in single cell
analysis also is becoming more popular
because earlier people use pca but now
now i wonder if you can say that to say
in this context you take the log of the
mutation frequency
rather than the organizational count
matrix and then you do pca on that
you say on the log count and then
what are the negative values positive
components is just multiplicative
factors
so
first
what we have here that we would like to
uh what's the advantage of the
non-negative matrix factorization and
also our furthermore delta is uh
have composition of the type signature
we call them primary secondary and the
secondary signature
of primary is that in the process of
online automatic cycles and the process
of the our non-additive model we also
infer the signatures
all right
we
you know it's about component analysis
it wouldn't
provide you
with those uh signatures at the end
but um
only these are multiplicative signatures
rather than the assets
i think that's as a good discussion one
interesting uh an important fact about
this work by alexander
is that you have this um
way of thinking about mutational
processes and they will just jump on it
so whenever you have to cancel data they
will decompose them into those
signatures so we now have like not only
we have the list of the signatures we
also have papers where to look
what's being known which cancers they've
been found so so this is kind of
um
because there was lots of excitement and
still is about this subject so we have a
very quick collections of the
literatures that
that you know
a wave that that was the interpreter so
that's one of the things but but i think
our point is about it this is not the
only way robert had another approach to
doing signatures more like machine
learning to type of
so so this is not that but it's very
convenient because because so many
we have so many painters that already
are like those
so um
all these all these computation patterns
that you look at like in the mutations
in the middle and you look at
one neighbor
but if you increase that you have a
larger context are you going to better
stratify some of the biological
processes
absolutely absolutely so it's not only
you can increase the confidence but then
you don't have enough data but in fact
alone
that you know
for for uh
for some of the processes like um let me
see this maybe not this one but for for
uh you will like the only one before
matter
for apple pack actually you know there
is
based on the experimental evidence you
actually know which positions matter and
those would be different positions in
different signatures that makes it a
little bit more challenging and also
uh you know also you have to somehow
figure out that if you you know cannot
extend this uh
uh factor too much because we will
be unless we have much more uh genomic
data
to fill the the profile so so that this
is a trailer between data and and how
much
how many different
mutational
categories
yeah
so 96 triplet mutation types i guess
you're boxing by a complimentary strand
is there more to learn if you don't do
that
yes
mutation so of course we have to we have
to we have to collapse because we never
know
which plant was the mutated one right so
so but but indeed you know indeed uh
this is the little banks of these
regions right
um
you know within genomic regions we can
go transcription not necessary we also
want to do another thing as you know
with him
with him as say
what's also important in
what's important determinant of the
signature is also a replication typing
and then you have leading and logging
stuff for example aquaback which is
known to
attack single standard dna in the
replication those strands are symmetry
with the
context which uh one is more exposed to
other reputations so that's yet another
another way you can you can you will
have to
accommodate and uh like in our laptops
we just chop it into regions um
classes and having kind of
you know data driven maybe some other
partitioning
and also in our approach we divide them
into blocks of the replication time
and there are some uh some uh
tons of analysis uh proposed where
people are trying to
uh to put it all together all of them
but still chopping up information
very good but we must continue now
again
we must